l'histoire du Titanic allait dans les
objets on tire une ficelle et puis on
ramène toute une histoire
[Musique]
j'ai eu la chance de faire partie de la
première équipe qui est arrivé sur les
pavs on est arrivé en plus sur la partie
la plus belle de l'épave qui les travaux
et c'est assez on avait travaillé dessus
depuis plus d'un an etc donc c'était
assez émouvant
[Musique]
96 il y a une expédition qui a été menée
par à l'initiative de Canal+ et de
Discovery une chaîne américaine et donc
les gens qui participaient aux
expéditions nous avons dit nous on sait
pas pourquoi le bateau a coulé on ne l'a
pas vu au fond donc ça a été l'idée de
départ si vous voulez de cette
expédition c'est de dire il faut qu'on
trouve les raisons exactes du naufrage
donc de voir à travers le sédiment
puisque le bateau s'étend enfoui dans le
sédiment on ne pouvait pas voir cette
fameuse brèche d'en parler la commission
d'enquête bref qui finalement n'existe
pas puisqu'il s'agit de petites
dans son film exactement il a refait son
scénario dans ce sens là
c'est un exploit technologique d'arriver
à plonger jusqu'à 3800 mètres de
récupérer des objets de différentes
tailles fragiles ou pas quand on essaie
de récupérer une tasse à café par 3800
mètres avec un sous-marin qui pèse quand
même 18 tonnes il y a comme le poids
d'un virement et qui a des bras
manipulateur on est obligé de fabriquer
des outils spéciaux tout ça demande
beaucoup de technologie beaucoup de
savoir-faire
[Musique]
cette aventurier va tenter l'impossible
pour retrouver l'avion d'Air France
ratissé 2000 km² dans une zone de vallée
subaquatique profonde de près de 4000
mètres
si l'épave de l'avion est localisée des
robots capables de descendre à plus de
6000 mètres tenteront de remonter les
boîtes noires à l'aide de ses bras
articulés pilotés à distance grâce à une
petite manette en mettant un petit outil
au bout on récupère une tasse à café
quoi et en même temps vous pouvez
soulever une pièce d'une de 100 kg et la
retourner quoi donc oui c'est il y a de
la puissance mais il y a aussi de la
dextérité
Cameron a eu des problèmes techniques au
bout d'un moment il était obligé de
remonter parce qu'il y a plein qui
arrivaient après les autres parce que
c'est quand même au-delà tout on arrive
à des pressions qui sont telles que les
tout est compressible le métal est
compressible et fortement
[Musique]
j'entends depuis 35 ans que les pas va
disparaître dans 20 ans donc elle est
toujours là et donc elle s'abîme de plus
en plus mais pas plus vite que
d'habitude il y en a quand même à mon
avis pour 200 ou 300 ans facilement
avant que tout disparaisse
[Musique]